edwards ça sonne salut c'est génial
c'est magnifique
t'as pas changé je savais que tu étais
mon premier amour était mon premier
amour a fait pas ça il est trop faible
pour toi ce que tu aimes chez lui finira
par te faire horreur j'ai vraiment tout
fait pour devenir celle que tu imaginer
que j'étais quand on aime quelqu'un il
faut faire attention on vit pas ça deux
fois mon ex mari m'avait surnommé animal
nocturne
je savais pas que tu avais un espoir et
tu les mets
je lui fais quelque chose d'horrible
j'ai quitté et 100 m demain qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
la question c'est de savoir si vous
tenez à réellement à ce que justice soit
faite
vous êtes cinglés petite grosse erreur
je reviendrai toute ma vie d'avoir fait
ça
si on les laisse partir y vont en baver
à pas savoir quand ça va leur tomber
dessus
personne ne peut s'en sortir en ayant
fait ce qui est parfait